our nervous system is just like a tube
and with a tube with the
disproportionate length maybe tapering
at one end so our brain and our spinal
cord is just a tube of varying diameter
but think in terms of development then
when our body starts from a cell the
zygote and the zygote divides into
several cells and these cells eventually
form the blastocyst and the blastocyst
has a chunk of cells these chunk of
cells need to be flattened in form of a
sheet and then it need to form the whole
tube so how this geometrical problem is
solved is an interesting question and
intrigue the scientists for over decades
so in this video we'll be talking about
how the neural tube forms so after
gastrulation in the gastrula where you
have all the three layers and if you cut
that grass drooler you would have a view
like this if you cut the grass gastrula
in a middle section mid level section
you would have a view like this in here
in blue you can see the ectoderm in
yellow you can see the mesoderm and in
brown you can see the endoderm at least
three germ layers are formed right now
now in this situation you have the
notochord which is derived from the
Missal term and notochord plays a
central role in terms of development of
the neural tube at specification of the
nervous system so new record is itself
generated by an indentation called a
primitive feet which is actually
elongated in a row stroke order axis to
form a primitive streak now new record
defines the midline of the embryo now
the epithelia which is
just above the notochord the part of
ectoderm is known as new reactor and why
this part of epithelia is different from
its adjacent neighbors we would talk
about it later
so definitely they're different in terms
of cellular properties however this new
reactor arm eventually the new reactor
term which is above the notochord folds
and this folding is known as neural fold
and due to this folding a groove or a
pit is formed which is called as neural
groove now the edges of the neural fold
kind of invaginate inside and you can
imagine when it invaginate it almost
form a tube like structure and
eventually the tube closes now the
neural tube closure is complete now when
the neural tube closure is complete
there are some cells which are detached
from the neural ectoderm known as the
neural crest cells and there are several
species inside the neural tube which are
specifically defined as a morphogen
gradient source such as the region just
above the notochord which is known as
the floor plate and the region which is
above in the roof side of that it's
called a roof plate so these roof plate
and full plate are source of morphogen
which is so important for neuronal
development and development of the
nervous system indeed now you can
understand that the floor plate is
actually this the notochord and the full
plate is actually the reach source for
SH whereas the roof plate is a source
for wheat and BMPs so there is an
opening gradient of wind and SSH in the
dorsal ventral axis so in the dorsal
ventral axis these differential gradient
determines how the tissue is
experiencing the wind and BM PN SSH
signal and depending upon the degree
it's experiencing about these morphogen
they've formed different structure now
at day 25 almost the neural tube folding
is complete neural tube folding starts
from the middle part and spreads in
rostral and caudal direction it's almost
complete so the tube is now well-defined
and a long side of the tube the meso
normal tissue forms the somites and you
can see the neural crest cells form a
several population now you would be
amused to know that the neural tube give
rise to the central nervous system that
means your brain and spinal cord whereas
the neural crest cells give rise to the
components of your peripheral nervous
system now we would look at how the
adherence properties several cell layers
in the neural tube is so important in
terms of the folding so initially
everything every part of the ectoderm
contains epithelial kattiline because it
is part of epithelia but due to the
influence of notochord a portion starts
Express ECOD having a in gatoring and
stop expressed ekaterina that becomes
the new rector term so the in contrarian
expression domain becomes a new retina
and the nearby domain still express iike
tearing now one wants the folding starts
eventually there are other structures
emerging like the neural crest cells or
even in that folded neural tube there
are floor plate and roof plate now it
turns out that the floor plate the cells
in the full plate they express scatter
in 6b hand the neural crest cells
express scattering 7 so due to these
difference in the adhesion properties
the neural crest cells can detach from
their origin and they can migrate away
so this is so important because cell
adhesion properties deep in mind that
how the two folding happens and how
sorting of these cells happen so this is
super important in terms of neural
development itself now
after the neural tube has been closed
the nervous system would balloon up and
form a tube which is kind of getting
elongated in one side and getting more
spherical in other side so there are
primitive brain regions which would be
formed at the end of three weeks and the
regions would be forebrain midbrain and
hindbrain
now these embryo would eventually at
eleven week have a complete development
developmental architecture of a adult
brain but still lot of rewiring and
neuronal migration and many other things
is happening even at embryonic day 11 at
embryonic day 11 weeks so by that time
the nervous system has start already
developed now I hope you enjoyed this
video in other videos we will be talking
about defects in neural tube folding and
many other things so for that if you
like my video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you